in five four three two one welcome
everybody to another episode of the
genius brain podcast what's going on
recording hey man I've done that mistake
seven times now I'll never do it for an
eighth you guys do it today you know
it's a Thursday which means we have Joji
Sakawa in the house what about people of
the world yes people it's been a it's
been a it's been a blessed blessed month
and week I hope it's been going really
great for you we've been doing certain
topics that had been riling up some
people's feathers here and there but I
like it I've been really into the recent
podcasts man yeah I'm getting a lot of
messages a lot of dm's a lot of people
are just supportive and they're like man
I love your guys's passion yeah I love
that you guys are representing a
different voice in the Asian community
and I'm all like we exist yeah obviously
in the comments there's a lot of people
that agree with us yeah but we're not
speaking out we as in the people that
think like us yeah so that's why we got
a champion this thought man it's a huge
[ __ ] community within the community
but everyone that's being represented is
the weak ass [ __ ] for example on next
sharkman I commented recently Ben baller
was talking about how Asians are like
tend to be soft and we need to be harder
right and there were so many comments in
like just bitch-ass comments dude you
have a dissected [ __ ] talk [ __ ] I'm like
all he's saying is you know like toughen
up to the point where you're not being a
victim and you're being a problem solver
mm-hmm and problem solver there's a
difference between like someone who's
standing up and actually making an
impact and doing something and there's a
difference between that and someone who
says I'm speaking out and spreading
awareness but in reality you're just
perpetuating [ __ ] just like how we
were talking about you're just spreading
all this like weak-ass stereotype [ __ ]
yeah it's like you're doing worse right
like some people they think they're
speaking out by saying hey we're not
gonna stand for this anymore but in
return you sound like a weasel that's
trying to get respect yeah you don't get
respect that way and I think it's hard
sometimes because when we did that video
about
of talking about Asian masculinity and
how Asian guys can't get girls which is
what a lot of people prescribe to I
think there was a big misconception
where I think we talk very passionately
right so it sounds like there's no
empathy like I think what I wanted
people to get away from that is yeah we
can cherry-pick certain things right so
if for example somebody wrote that like
he goes hey well I live in Ecuador I'm
the only Asian it's like what we're not
talking about you [ __ ] you know talking
about Asian Americans and that by the
way you're talking about a
fish-out-of-water scenario which yeah of
course it's gonna be like that for any
ethnicity that it doesn't just mean
Asian people so we're talking about
people who have that power to to really
change perception right and there was a
lot of people who wrote in the comments
where they said that they grew up in a
predominantly white area and they dated
perfectly fine so what the point is is
that you can't I don't want people to
blanket all Asian American the Asian
American experience to be one thing
right right so what our point in this
was is that's exactly what we're against
is creating this monolithic thought yeah
we're going against this thing of hey
we're representative of the Asian
culture of the Asian American community
and this is how it is for us there's a
lot of people out there there's Asian
influencers out there that are like
championing this [ __ ] victim
mentality as if it's fact well because
they like the fact that people kind of
attach to their to their thought and
they get they get power from it right
they're like yeah I'm just like you I
want to feel sorry for myself if my
heroes feel sorry for themselves
I could feel sorry for myself and I just
don't want to perpetuate I got that word
down now I mother [ __ ] perpetuate that
[ __ ] because it's not who I am and I and
I do understand where you're coming from
but it does take individuals such as
yourself and new people out there to
really stand up to that [ __ ] because
it's not going to change if you just sit
there and complain it doesn't do
anything yeah and you know we can we
could talk about this and I'm not saying
it's easy right it is difficult and even
sometimes and in that perspective helps
out a lot too because for me it wasn't
very difficult because I didn't put that
mental block in my head and I started
making things happen for myself so a big
misconception to was like they're like
if somebody wrote well I think you guys
live in a certain bubble because I don't
think you guys have clearly dated people
outside who were Asian and I'm like bro
you clearly don't know anything because
Bart has been married and been with a
Mexican woman for the longest time yeah
Kasey has also been with the Mexican and
married a Mexican woman Bart was a Joe
was with a white girl for five [ __ ]
years exactly but before that I've dated
a lot of Asian girls and Latino I mean
like it's just literally be you know
publicly is what you saw exactly I've
dated multicultural like it's it's crazy
how people think yeah and you know
depending on where you live to you
probably live in an area yet let's just
say that you live in an area where there
aren't oh you're like the only 1 or 2 3
Asians out there so yeah people are
going to have certain thoughts about you
about a culture that they don't know or
understand but that goes for anything
yeah is what I'm saying like you can't
you can't take that very specific
instance of yourself being a fish out of
water saying that's how it is for
everybody because it's not yeah and then
you and I guess at the end of the day
what I'm trying to say is that I'm on
your side like I want to exactly I want
to really just like boost up your
self-esteem and say that even though you
aren't it like a dis advantageous
situation specifically in the gaming
game where you are that only Asian guy
out there and people have they might may
have certain negative stereotypes that
prevent them from dating you you have a
chance to prove some things prove these
people wrong and the show why you're so
great and why your culture is great too
and that's what I think that's what
masculinity is yeah masculinity is
really going for the goal you're not
stopping at the first sign of resistance
because you don't deserve the dating and
you don't deserve the girl or the job or
anything if you don't fight for it so
when I take it from these guys right or
these people in general when they say
all but we got it harder than them or if
they say something like well they don't
have to deal with the same type of
stigma that we do and I'm like okay that
might be true and I do agree you know
for some girl from some groups it might
be easier but at the same time who cares
yeah who cares if it's easy
so [ __ ] what you have to work harder
at the end of the day I guarantee you
when you work hard for something you
cherish it that much more yeah you
shouldn't have to audition to erase to a
racist obviously if there's girls out
there that just already judge you before
you even get with them they're not even
your type they shouldn't be your type
are you that desperate to the point
where you have to convince these women
you don't have to audition for them but
all I'm saying is you also have the
power to go you don't know nothing let
me show you how awesome I am and that's
what a [ __ ] man does you don't think
oh you don't like me you [ __ ] turn
around and cry I just also exactly I
wear many masks like I don't I also
don't want people to find the research
behind statistics to stay the way that
they are and I think that's what a lot
of these young guys are doing right like
well did you see what OkCupid wrote
OkCupid said that it's very hard for age
it's like cool but you keep finding
reasons for you to stay down
right all the time instead of finding a
reason for you to stand up and then kind
of fight for what you want and that's
what a man does yeah my opinion if you
want to talk about masculinity right a
man is a leader a man takes what the
[ __ ] they whatever situation they get
and makes the best [ __ ] soup out of
it right so if you're letting yourself
go well why try anyway no woman finds
that attractive I guarantee you that's
that's the mentality that bothers me
it's it's you you want to pair each
aperi cherry-pick evidence that bolsters
your negative thoughts and say why try
because these factors over here says
that I say that I'm not attractive and
it's like that's the thing that's hard
for me to get on to that's the battery
and I don't want to get on I don't
because to me that's failing before you
start and I don't have that mentality in
life in period and I and I think we're
specifically talking about dating but it
I'm pretty sure these guys they apply
this to everything I'm sure that they're
not living their dreams or doing a lot
of things and I can make this
generalization because once you have a
successful type of mindset that makes
you overcome obstacles you will apply
this
system of thinking - almost everything
you do in life yeah because if you are a
go-getter you're just gonna be a
go-getter that's that's all that is like
I mean if you you're not gonna be a
go-getter in sports and then like not be
a go-getter in other things you know
yeah III don't think hopefully this is
not a generational thing but I have had
a couple of conversations with people
who are flannel I say six or seven years
younger than me right which isn't that
big of an age gap but it seems like it
is an age gap in terms of where they're
at mentally and kind of the things that
they really believe keeps them down
which is the stuff that I like to refute
a lot right so yeah we talk about
perspective a lot and though it sounds
really repetitive it's very important
because how I see other people situation
when they complain about things not to
say that I'm not empathetic and you
can't complain about things that make
you feel bad but it's really just
believing in the fact that you can't do
anything about your situation that's
really hard for me to really kind of
agree with right so right for example I
had a conversation with a young lady a
really good friend of mine amazing
individual and you know she's working a
full-time job and she's like um like I
kind of worked towards this thing that I
thought was going to be great and
finally at where I want to be and it's
not as great as I thought and now I have
to find a new job like I don't know what
I'm doing and you know in my mind and
you know she's going on like an hour
diatribe about how terrible her life is
but in my opinion I'm like okay so you
somehow managed to get the successful
career that you wanted in two years
that's [ __ ] wild and you're still
[ __ ] young you're still in your
mid-20s which means you still have a
[ __ ] ton of time to figure out you have
no kids no debt no nothing yeah
if life is pretty good right now man
it's all perspective it's all
perspective it's like you have this
ability to now with nothing holding you
down financially or physically yeah and
now you just have to figure out a new
job and like well I've been trying and
like I think like her thing that she was
saying is like well in your career you
could kind of create your own destiny I
was like cool well if you want my career
then work for it then yeah don't don't
don't look it's not like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] in your career out and you got
lucky exactly it fought for it exactly
so it's like if you want to fight for
what I have be my
you can but how I got to be where I am
now
yeah you're only seeing the 10 spot but
you're not seeing number 1 through 9
that I had to go through to get here you
didn't see the fact that I had to sell
all my [ __ ] to come to this place you
didn't see the fact that I had a couple
hundred dollars in my bank account
living off of ramen with the [ __ ]
spring mattress and a single desk like
you weren't there for that moment right
and I never and I never did this thing
where I show people how lavish I live
because I never got to that point so
it's like it was a it was a very hard
grind for me to end up where I am and I
just showed a lot of gratitude during
that process so I still carry that
gratitude all the way through even when
it was tough when I had these
opportunities to do stand-up without any
pay but I got a 5-minute spot then I got
a 10-minute spot what's not fair is that
when people see where we're at or
whatever they go oh easy for you to say
because all you're doing is talking
about you know how you did it through
hard work but you guys got lucky and to
me it's a lot of [ __ ] when people
say that because what they're doing is
they're discrediting how much sacrifices
we made how many [ __ ] 70 hour weeks
or whatever the [ __ ] we did sleepless
nights spending two hours to sleep every
single night for four days straight how
many birthdays we missed families with
things that we mean there's things that
we've sacrificed to [ __ ] get here
yeah but they're discrediting they're
discrediting all of that and they're
saying well that's cuz you got lucky
yeah and I'm like okay [ __ ] the
reason why I talk so much [ __ ] and the
reason why I spread this stuff and the
reason why I do it because I care so
much and I want other people to realize
that if you want it to there is an
alternative you don't have to do what
people tell you to do you don't have to
do that there is an alternative there is
a way out if you don't like where you're
at and the only reason why I care so
much is cuz I wish someone told that
[ __ ] to me when I was younger oh yes
right and when I see it in them it
pisses me off because I'm almost kicking
myself saying hey get the [ __ ] up man
yeah so when there are people that are
down and out sure I could approach it in
a more nurturing and loving way but the
frustration comes from a place of
goddammit dude I care so much I want you
guys to realize it I want everyone to
realize it I think there's a huge
problem in our community like the reason
why it's never good enough for a lot of
people is because culturally we're
taught that way from our parents right
this podcast is brought to you by
Skillshare my friends argue about
lifelong learning well let me tell you
about skills share my friends let's have
you learn on your own accord on your own
time let's have a huge database for
knowledge that you could pick apart from
from people who know what they're
talking about that right there is skill
share skill share is an online learning
community where millions come together
to take the next step in their creative
journey thousands of inspiring classes
for creative and curious people on
topics including illustration design
photography video freelancing and more
Skillshare offers classes designed for
real life so you can move your creative
journey forward without putting it on
hold you can learn and grow with short
classes that fit your busy routine the
class that I enjoy especially for people
out there that want to get into
photography you have to know how to use
your tool so I go to the class of
fundamentals of DSLR photography it's
actually a great course it gets you a
lot of the knowledge that you'll skip by
just by clicking that red button every
time that you shoot the DSLR is is more
complicated than that and it does
require some know-how especially for
those of you out there that really do
want to take your hobby a little more
seriously than just clicking away on a
button so give that class ago if you
sign up or when you sign up because it
will help you out so explore your
creativity and get two free months of
premium membership at skill share comm
slash brain that's two whole months of
unlimited access of thousands of classes
for free get started and joined today by
heading to Skillshare comm slash brain
that's two free months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes at
Skillshare comm slash brain go harder go
harder you got to get eight pluses
whatever so even if you get the good
grade it's like you're supposed to get
the good grade mm-hmm you never
celebrate your wins yeah so over the
years I try my best to figure out what
to do in these situations how to rewrite
my program and that's why I came out
with like 90 days to freedom and things
like that because I think people don't
have the right support and mentality to
get out of the situation
that they're in yeah and also to its you
know as I say these things you know
whatever you're going through though it
seems very large and very hard to get
through and and as I give this advice
I'm still actually going through what
you're going through I'm just handling
it a lot differently so I'm still it's a
figuring out process though I am though
I have a general idea of what I want to
do now five years from now four years
from now maybe six or ten it might
change and I have to accept that fact I
think that change part scares a lot of
people they go well what if I do this
and then three years down the line I
don't want to do it anymore
that's life [ __ ] that happens all the
time you are not guaranteed anything in
this life the only thing that you're
[ __ ] guaranteed in life is death
that's about the thing is the
uncertainty right it scares you have to
go back to that being confident and not
just masculinity but just being a leader
you have to walk into risk knowing that
it might be wrong but who the [ __ ] cares
because you made a decision and you're
gonna follow it through and this is the
type of confidence and certainty and
whatever that I want to teach people
because like at the end of the day
whether it's dating love like long-term
relationships or whatever it is a
marriage and and all that it's like a
business deal but with even more with
emotions and things right and and if
both partners aren't leaders a lot of
damage can could happen if you have two
[ __ ] kids dating and that's what
usually happens isn't to selfish little
kids or dating and then they could be
forty it doesn't matter they keep going
through all these divorces because they
haven't figured out how to [ __ ] lead
themselves yeah and when I see the [ __ ]
out there from in cells and everyone
like there's not a [ __ ] leader among
them nobody speaks as if they're ready
to take [ __ ] into their own hands change
their situation and make it better for
themselves and I really want I don't
want to just say this generation but
people in general I'm really like out
here trying to change all of that
because I think whenever we've been on
JK news a lot of this stuff that we talk
about it's really to change that thought
and to kind of change perspective and
show that
there is another way of living and by
living it thinking it having friends
that also think the same way and support
that thought I feel like a lot of people
want to be like that but in their own
friends and family they get stuck
because a lot of people push them down
crabs in a bucket you know mm-hmm they
don't want to challenge themselves to do
better so they don't want other family
members and friends to do differently
because then it's gonna make them feel
like [ __ ]
and I see a lot of this and it's really
smart to have that type of mentality too
and I've learned this from other people
now this is not something that I thought
of but a lot of the times people find
things to blame for the reason why they
didn't get a specific amount of success
even though they follow these certain
steps and the reason why is because
people are they truly believe that
there's a certain amount of certainty in
life right and because they don't have
that stability and certainty and it
didn't happen even though they made the
right choices they say [ __ ] everything
why do I try at all but like I said
before the only thing guaranteed in your
life is [ __ ] death that's really about
it yeah and why I say this is because
sometimes some of you [ __ ] out
there and this was me when I was younger
is like I would read this book this
inspirational book and it's like this
[ __ ] told me that I would my
life was gonna change I did X amount of
things and it didn't change the way that
I wanted to and they feel like it's a
waste of time yeah but it's not a waste
of time though like you leveled up in
one type of way or another and that's
just how life turns out to be you try
something out if it doesn't [ __ ] work
you pick up your pieces and you move on
and you try something else
after that the biggest biggest problem
that I personally had was my my problem
of inactivity due to too many options
it's something that I'm still going
through right now that I really have to
learn how to cut all the [ __ ] out
stick to stick to a plan and just see it
through all the way it's funny because
some people don't even know what their
passion is and you got like 20 that's
the hard part right I got a lot of [ __ ]
I love and I want to do really well
yeah we're just we're wait we're in an
age of luxury we're weighed down by a
lot of options and I've said this before
with my buddy Chris when he was on you
know Christina so so it's like you're
not really lost you're just you have too
many options you don't know what to pick
you know but you have to pick something
and
yeah and it's very counterintuitive when
I hear people they say this they go well
okay I got this isn't that but I don't
want to waste my time if I do this and
it turns I don't good at something else
so conversely you're just gonna sit
around and do nothing either way you're
wasting time yeah I could relate to
because I switched my major like [ __ ]
five six amen double major [ __ ] for
minors baby yeah cuz we all in that
stage in the early stages I'm sure if
you're listening you're at you're if
you're 20 19 years old or whatever
you're probably in college and you're
probably like man I don't know what I'm
gonna choose for the rest of my life now
you know and I've been there to where
I'm like oh should I be a music major
should I be a medical should I be a
psychiatrist should I be this and it's
hard to choose before you even you even
taste that world mm-hmm cuz a lot of my
friends who are professionals they went
through mad years of schooling they got
their bachelor's they got their masters
and then they go into engineering they
go to accounting whatever and then two
years into it they realized this is not
for me a lot of our business partners
almost all of our business partners
actually in the restaurant group they
have a professional degree jeunes a
lawyer jeremy has a master's in
engineering a civil engineering I think
Anna built a business she knew what she
wanted after her bachelor's and then Dan
actually had a restaurant yeah but also
there are people within the group too
that have degrees that they don't use
such as me like I have a psychology
degree you know I I guess I kind of use
it because what we do involve psychology
but I'm not in the field I'm not like a
licensed psychologist or anything yeah
so what I tell people is just choose
something you don't have to stick with
it but choose something that your heart
says this is what I want to learn is
what I want to kill it at because don't
do the thing where a lot of people do
they go they make a they make a
sacrifice though well I guess this makes
enough money and I can kind of learn to
love it that's what most people [ __ ]
do right and they all regret it I don't
know one [ __ ] that did that and
they're there in a lackluster job and
they're like you know what I learned to
live with it and I think it's cool I've
rarely [ __ ] seen that happen in most
cases what people do is they'll be like
guess I could learn to love this it pays
well they get into it they [ __ ] hate
it and they go I always knew what I
wanted to do why didn't I have the
courage to do that yeah and this is the
same thing with the whole masculinity
talk we were talking about or dating or
whatever deep down inside people know
what they want they know the type of
love they want they know the person that
they want to date they know their
preferences or whatever but do they go
out there and get what they want I don't
know yeah and if and if also to their
there's a certain amount of people out
there they're you know they're happy
with where they're what they're doing
and you know their ambitions kind of
like where they're at right now that's
also okay too
there's a lot of group there's there's
only a set amount of people in this
world that's really gonna be a leader
right
yeah really like you mean you could be a
leader in your community or in your own
life and that's great but you know
that's what I'm saying like when you
sometimes when you read these books and
you know you sign up for certain things
and but the point of those things aren't
to tell you that you're guaranteed
success
what it is is trying to get you into the
right mind state so you can be as
successful as you can be when you try to
tackle these things right because that's
the variability in life like you have to
accept that [ __ ] it even goes Eitam and
bleeds into a lot of people who are
trying to find happiness there's so many
people out there especially when I talk
to people who have dealt with a lot of
depression was a belief in certainty
like they look at somebody else and they
see certainty and somebody else's
happiness there how come I'm not happy
like that what why do I feel this way
why do I feel sad you know and obviously
there's there's a whole scientific thing
about depression and you know the
chemical imbalance in your head we're
not gonna get into that but but a lot of
the common traits of depression is
people think grass is greener yeah I
like I've seen that a lot and you guys
heard me talk about depression a lot
with a lot of guests who have come on
here and that has been the common factor
in a lot of their stuff yeah it was it
was that concept and it's hard to kind
of break out at that ship but it does
take it does take you as an individual
to kind of take individual individual to
take that step yeah I mean it's scary
too because it's a confidence issue
right like you've been taken care of
most of your life most people that are
listening your parents or whatever right
and then here comes adulthood now you
have to make your own decisions but
you weren't taught how to think for
yourself the school told you what you
what to do your parents told you what to
do
you weren't really taught to think and
and lead your own self your own mind
right even the way you dressed people
taught you how to do that then you might
explore you might find individualism in
different styles or whatever or like a
political thought or whatever and then
you become a full-on adult you get your
job you go into your career but still
people are telling you what to do you
have a boss whatever whatever so when a
human is built this way it's difficult
for them to take full responsibility and
full anything and I don't blame them for
that because all their lives they were
led and they were always fighting
against someone who was telling them
what to do mm-hmm but how do you get
someone like that and all of a sudden
overnight okay you're an adult now be an
adult that's hard that's like Asian
Asian parents right like the stereotype
is like they say you can't date and and
then when you hit late 20s they're like
why aren't you married yet yeah and it's
like what the [ __ ] you said I can't [ __ ]
or date or anything I didn't have
practice and then all of a sudden like
I'm socially awkward and all this stuff
and I don't have any friends and all of
a sudden you want me to be married yeah
like what's wrong with your [ __ ] they
kind of sell them on the same dream two
of and it might be an Asian or just an
immigrant parent thing of they say [ __ ]
like where if you go to college you'll
get a big paint job
that's though already the rhetoric is
wrong it's not that you go to college
you get a big paying job is your chances
are higher for you to be successful in
life that's really what it is it just
gives you the better probability and
we've talked about how people are hired
before and what those degrees are for
and you ask any person that hire
somebody what that degrees for it's just
the easy way for us to be like cool I
want people with a with the diploma or a
degree because I know that they can
follow instructions and they can follow
through with something and then
everybody else will interview them after
these people because these are the pic
of our litter nobody looks at your
[ __ ] grades really especially you
know but maybe when I hire people I
don't go
maybe plus B plus people never really
[ __ ] done that yeah you know so it
helps your probability I think it's you
know a lot of
parents they do set up their kids for
failure because again telling them about
this Promised Land that's not there
they don't teach them steps like my dad
used to get upset at me for not knowing
how to do things but I remember we got I
used to fight with him about this like
because you never let me do it yeah
every time I try it you go give me that
[ __ ] you don't know what you're doing
you're dumb it's like yeah well let me
[ __ ] try and then if I don't want to
try goes why aren't you doing it's like
because you're gonna take it away from
me anyway so I even try at this point
that's true that you're going to get mad
and you know for him it kind of came
from a really good place in his heart
but he didn't see the negative effects
it had on me as a child but I eventually
even in that relationship I had to say
hey I'm gonna [ __ ] do this and we
butted heads all the time because of it
it was so [ __ ] hard it's almost like
he feel like he had this point where he
just didn't want me to fail so he would
try to do things for me but then if I
did something and I failed it was still
my fault
so it was like he didn't want it
confusing yeah yeah I just didn't know
what the [ __ ] to do when it goes back to
the whole leadership right he really
didn't know how to lead you you know and
how to help guide you he just kind of
shot in the dark with no point yeah and
then he [ __ ] that up obviously yeah so
it's all it's I think it's like a
generational thing of like not breeding
good leaders even in Asian culture right
its Confucianism you just kick up the
idea to the top yeah so your dad listens
to grandpa listens to government listens
to whatever
no one's developing independent thought
so I don't blame you know Asian American
males or whatever I don't blame them for
not being a leader I'm just like now I
have the tools to and I think I've done
it for for a long time where I want to
show other people how to do it too
because we need more leaders in our
community that can [ __ ] take the
bullets and say [ __ ] it let's go let's
roll I want other like-minded Asians or
just people in general that are down to
take responsibility are down to take
their own lives into their own hands and
change the system and change the way
that things are right so change
perception don't just [ __ ] complain
about it like if you are someone that
might be undesirable what
get yourself out there and show the
world how [ __ ] beautiful we are yeah
inside outside the way we are just in
general right you're the best salesman
to do it the real-life experience that
people have of you your culture or
whatever that's the impression that
people get not [ __ ] Hollywood not all
these other things like obviously if
there's no Asians and you're in their
neighborhood that's what the information
that they get but if you're the access
right
unfortunately because there's no
representation you are the
representative I know it sucks to have
the whole race on your shoulders but
that's the bird and that we got because
you know it's just you got to play your
cards that you're given don't get mad
get ahead and that's what I say don't
get even get ahead you always want to
[ __ ] win and change the whole thing
going back to the whole reason why Asian
parents might be the way they are
setting up their kids like that for
college I think there's two things my
mom once told me that she was surprised
that the system was different for
education here versus Japan she says out
there if you kill it in high school you
get that you there's like a test that
that determines what college you go to
like they're interesting exams yeah
yeah and once you pass this test at a
high level you basically that test
determines the rest of your life if you
get a high high high test score you you
pretty much accepted into the top Ivy
League's
of Japan you go in there you're pretty
much if you high school or whatever
you're pretty much accepted into the top
positions or the top businesses or the
whatever right career might be very
similar so similar a lot of Japanese
kids are maybe Chinese or Korean or
whatever if the system is the same when
they come to America they don't question
that it might be different here because
the language barrier and all that stuff
so they just go kill it in those tests
do really really well once you make
sense yeah and then once you get that
she's like you're guaranteed a job
because that's how it worked in their
generation in in their country another
thing I think is if you're the first
Asian of your if you're the first person
of your family to become a university
student
chances are your parents aren't college
educated they're not high school
educated maybe chances are they are not
they're illiterate chances are they're
war refugees they have no [ __ ] idea
they heard from someone hey you got to
be a pharmacist you got to be a doctor
you got to be whatever so they press
that [ __ ] to their kids another thing is
I know in the Vietnam War is they read
they saved all the doctors because
they're like oh we need them for society
when we rebuild so don't kill the
doctors yeah oh don't kill the medical
people so they're like oh you know
pharmacist doctor medical that's the
jobs that are not risky you become one
your respected in society so those are
the things that that are kind of
ingrained in their minds and they're
doing their best to kind of tell their
kids to be that yeah that makes sense
too and it's it's I talked to this one
young lady who was talking who said one
of those ridiculous things I remember I
was just clowning on her ass I was like
oh we've known each other for a while
now so should I say what I'm gonna say
you take it however and what she was
basically saying was oh well like if I
fail at some things I'm just afraid of
what the community is gonna look at a
community exactly bro I was like the
[ __ ] cook who the [ __ ] are you doin
sir no she's nobody I was like what
community are you talking about that
means your futures do you think I guess
so is I think you think way too much
about people and what i stoled it's like
who the [ __ ] are you dude a lot of
people are [ __ ] narcissistic like that
you know that like what is this
community you're speaking about they're
all gonna talk about me like who who's
all like your mom and your brother yeah
I mean you know there are rumors that
spread but it goes in and out like that
people are not dwelling on your [ __ ]
life they're really not man and I might
have told the story before but there was
a church that I used to work for and
just to say how how [ __ ] people can
even try to tarnish her name but even
that shake it starts to disappear
because I used to work for this church
and it was a church that my dad started
up but long story short that guy
after he begged me to stay to be a youth
minister there to continue you know go
to seminary school and become a youth
minister I told him I couldn't it was a
whole amazing thing we left you know I
got a cake and everything I said my
goodbyes and I moved on well my buddy
ray his parents still attended that
church after well that pastor told
everybody that when I left I made a huge
scene to a bunch of church members like
in his office I made a huge scene I
cursed him out told him that the church
is trash and I [ __ ] left and I
rebuked him and I was on you lied he
lied I was like why did he say that
about me I got a cake yeah you son of a
[ __ ] well lo and behold long story
short - that guy actually stole like 50
grand from the church and bounced well
he prays he was a crook yeah and I was
like what the [ __ ] was but there was
people in that community that community
that small Korean community that thought
of me like I was [ __ ] garbage even
though I didn't do it and people talking
about it now in my life has moved on and
that [ __ ] hasn't affected me at all and
who cares it's Jerry who the [ __ ] cares
yeah but a lot of people are worried
about the community yeah the community
to think what community man just live
your own [ __ ] life we're all so wired
to like worry about the village no the
village is not gonna accept us yeah you
know it's just a weird concept like to
sit there and just worry about the small
people around you that that at the end
of the day people forget they have their
own lives to live like even I mean I
mean obviously yeah we're not talking
about like Cosby raping 80 girls right
obviously people never forget that type
of [ __ ] but we're talking about you may
be failing at something or embarrassing
yourself or something maybe not getting
the job that you wanted who the [ __ ]
made failing medical school yeah yeah I
mean a few ants might go around and
[ __ ] gossip but their lives are that
boring they got a gossip about you
that's even sadder that's really sad man
that's [ __ ] sad my best friend in
sacramento his he has somebody that was
in his graduating class because as a
doctor that guy was like in his almost
50 years old and he he originally was
doing like community [ __ ] right like
helping out late Louis I'd be like I
don't want it and I'm making a
generalization here but something on
like social service or some [ __ ] like
that help help
like something like that and he made a
switch and he's like I'm gonna become a
doctor he has a family he has a wife he
has kids and then he Danny went to
medical school that's dope right and
Tommen the guy's [ __ ] 50 dude like
damn near almost 50 years old and he
made that change so he what the [ __ ]
that's cool right yeah if somebody who's
you know inundated with family ties you
know he has bills to pay he has a wife
he can make that change he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about what people think I'm
pretty sure you can too and the biggest
difference is it's like who that
individual is like I met him he's a very
just nice dude you know he kind of
stands up really tall and he goes for
what he wants in life yeah sometimes I'm
like I want to shake people like why do
you think you're that important yeah why
the [ __ ] do you think you're that
[ __ ] important that people you think
that people are sitting there wondering
what you're doing all damn day and if
they do talk about you it'll be so brief
it'll be 20 minutes out of their time or
less it's like even the way like we
sometimes hate somebody right like we we
[ __ ] dislike somebody and we sit
around and we talk [ __ ] about them all
day but then at the same time I'm like
why do we do that like do you think that
purchasing around thinking about us like
that no probably not
and we're just wasting our [ __ ] time
and energy on an individual that doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about you they're
saying like I forgot who said this quote
but it was like when you try to destroy
your enemies by hating them it's like
drinking poison wishing that they died
mmm that's [ __ ] good yeah right
you're the only person that you really
hate like when you hate somebody the
only person that that suffering is you
yeah they can't feel that you know
that's true that's [ __ ] really good
that's actually great that's a great
[ __ ] analogy it's true yeah you spend
all of our time and energy on somebody
that doesn't really think about us like
that and nothing changes nothing happens
we just waste our time in our spirit and
that's it yeah it just depletes us
constantly we're just being depleted 24
[ __ ] 7 while this person thrives on
our age I like pretending to hate though
it's so for sure
like I love pretending petty because
it's also not fun to be so above it that
you don't feel anything mm-hmm
like I like to explore these natural
of human feelings of like pettiness
jealousy envy it's kind of fun to go in
and I like having enemies too it could
also be fuel too you could also use that
as fuel yeah I sometimes it's a really
good thing like my manager always says -
I'm like yo man these people don't think
I could deal he's like who's these
people community community I could do it
I gotta [ __ ] show them show them
what's up he goes dude I think everybody
thinks he could do this I'm like nah
they don't believe me I don't show the
most driven by that I love that - cuz I
mean when we did that podcast about the
whole Asian masculinity thing like ice
it was a trending topic right there were
some stuff that was posted on next shark
I saw this podcast on the Asian hustle
Network I responded to I was debating
some other people and I was like man
this is it this is a [ __ ] topic right
now yeah we got to [ __ ] say our point
because you know whenever something
comes up I used to do this thing where
I'm like Manish it's Patti I'm above it
mm-hmm
but then late that then my thoughts in
my words were never represented so I was
like hold the [ __ ] up man there's like
all these [ __ ] saying the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] them [ __ ] because I don't think
that way I need to speak up yeah and
then when we did that video a lot of
people were like oh thanks Joe like [ __ ]
man I thought I was the only one
surrounded by all these cowards yeah and
now you're the one that's actually like
saying the truth yeah and you know for
if you have friends like that in your
circle that that speak like that
I'd say like don't even come at them
really hard unless they're [ __ ]
annoying as [ __ ] but trying to uplift
them and see them like show them
something a little better yeah it's all
man cuz I'm really just trying to show
you what you with the ability out there
for you guys to do the stuff that you
really feel like you can't do because
it's it's really is a mentality flip
that's true cuz we sound like we're
saying shut up you insel [ __ ] yeah but
in reality we're saying hey little bro
life doesn't have to be that way yeah
but we just have our own way of [ __ ]
saying things [ __ ] man well we actually
have that oh let's do it
oh [ __ ] so we had a
we have this big fan by the name as
Christian King Christian Lopez Big Ups
to you he's pretty well-known and I
guess the disabled community he he's
he's a yeah what would you say like an
influencer he does his own thing but
he's a big supporter of us and I really
he created oh my god he's even wrote one
for you and Mariel I decided to open
this together because it says genius
brain right and I wanted to read it out
loud yeah so it says David and Mariel
wait a minute I thought he was gonna
have something for genius brain this is
just for me and that's the Mario
anyways I'll read this one to the
kinkajou Amalia congratulations on
danger boys it's great to finally meet
you thank you for existing jkf was one
of the first videos I've ever seen back
when I didn't know what YouTube was
being one of the first people to listen
to your thirty days of freedom during
its beta phase help me out big time and
seeing you upload again on YouTube
little fire and me to upload again after
six month hiatus watching your videos
got me motivated to upload things that
I'm interested in I share my spoken word
poems wheelchair POV of my concert
experience and wheelchair tips on living
life with a disability thank you for
creating the citizens of John Mallia
Facebook and Rome ahlian Academy the
groups are very supportive I shared my
first wheelchair wheelchair tip
Wednesday video and got so much love and
great feedback Jamali Academy helps me a
lot especially with topics that I didn't
learn in school I look forward to
learning more things in your Academy
wishing you a happy and awesome 2020
thanks Christian man yeah I actually met
Christian when Tim and I were doing this
it was Tim show and they had me just on
his thing where I was like a game show
with what I think that was a laugh house
or was it I forgot which comedy club it
was but we're basically doing like
stand-up jokes and it's a game show and
then he came out I think it was like
super really super supportive but he's
on yeah I think he supports everybody in
the jkf Network yeah and it's kind of
cool to see like what people get out of
what we do like it's weird because uh
I think up until maybe probably like
this year which is blowing like two
months in I
really had a purpose to really I mean it
sounds weird to kind of help people it
was just only for me to speak my mind
and hopefully people will agree with it
or if they don't then that's okay too
yeah right but now that I see the
positive effects that it have that's
obviously one of the reasons why I like
going to some of these college shows is
because I get to see the the the
positive effects I have on people right
not in just like entertaining them like
just make an impact yeah yeah it's
beyond just making somebody laugh it's
just that it's that thing where it's
like I never got to be around people
like you so when I got to hear what you
said on these videos like it really
helped me out through a lot of these
that's what it's all about is opening up
their reality for me it's opening up
people's worlds right I really want to
be a part of that process because I
enjoy connecting with people all over
the world and also I like to share my
thoughts because most of these thoughts
and conversations that we have to me
it's like sharing growth with each other
and going through the mistakes going
through life and again making sense of
that and sharing it again and I think
that's what brings us together as just a
human community it's not a race thing
it's not a culture thing it's just being
[ __ ] human and it's hard to navigate
this [ __ ] and it can get it can be
really hard but then when I'm out just
speaking and doing this what I'm hoping
is I can relieve that just a little bit
for people and they won't feel so alone
and so what we want to do also is do
genius brain light so if you all are a
part of colleges or whatever just email
us and I think it's in the description
or whatever they could let us know cuz I
want to do this real life I think we
make more of an impact when we speak to
them face to face yeah you know Laurel
you just to go back to I was saying to
like learning is a process that we're
all going through at the same time so
it's not really I don't want people to
think I'm like preaching at them right
it's just thoughts and I'm thinking
about that I always tell myself to
consistently so because if you're in a
mine state where somebody sometimes they
say things to you you know they try to
impart some type of wisdom and then your
first thought is oh you think that
you're better than me you're in a bad
space it's like dude when people ask me
that I'd be like yeah yeah I guess I am
I'm learning [ __ ] all the time and I
actually just had a I'm not sure if it's
gonna be out by the time this comes out
but if it is but there's a guy named
Jesse Jesse uh oh [ __ ] gosh oh yeah no
do you see small yay but Jesse from he
was in narcos oh yeah so you know looked
looked him up - just crazy IMDB page he
guy's been a working actor for so
[ __ ] long but you know just having
him come on and somebody who's older
than me that has a perspective on like
entertainment and acting really opened
up my eyes to like I'm always learning
[ __ ] right like it's telling that my
language in my perspective about acting
is wrong and I and I kind of listened to
what he had what he had to say and it
had helped me out I don't know
everything
I don't know [ __ ] to be honest with you
I'm the dumbest [ __ ] out there
but I'm always willing to learn so yeah
I think it's all about sharing what you
know for now cuz for me too I also leave
up I mean we've been on Jay King news
for what eight plus years I'll leave up
everything because there are things that
I got wrong or I believe back then that
I don't believe today but also I want to
show that there's growth mm-hmm and
everyone should continuously learn and
grow and it's all okay to be [ __ ]
wrong man yeah and we're all just
shooting in dark thinking that we got it
up we got life so far right so let's
play a four word is like hey most of our
listeners they might be 10 years younger
than us five years younger than us so
hopefully we did do life in a way where
we're ahead of them because what would
suck is you know you hear about a 16
year old who's also astronaut and he has
a billion-dollar business and you're
like damn okay well let me ask him some
questions that's right [ __ ] [ __ ] but
I'm just trying to be big brother yeah
cuz I wish I had that mm-hmm
and that's how I'm giving back value to
the world you know yeah hopefully
somebody takes something away from this
I mean it's obviously I'm not all the
podcasts or ever this serious but it is
something that I didn't want to bring up
just because there are so many things
like comments written in that video that
I wanted to respond to because not
because I cared that how people misheard
what I see you want to go through those
[ __ ] we can't actually shares
talk some [ __ ] I feel like [ __ ]
fighting right now mother
ah haha let's talk some [ __ ] well we got
to filter out the trolls though some
people just come in and get a reaction I
know Joe's are weird the way I block
most of them though
people like you know how I know that
they're a troll they're like they come
at you really shitty right as if they
don't even like you and then they go so
what's wrong
you can't take criticism by a fan and
I'm all like bro you do not sound like
anyone that loved me or care like I'm
okay with criticism all day every
[ __ ] day I actually love debating
that's one of my things I love arguing
and debating yeah let's start with this
one right here so this guy name is Chris
egg mm-hmm let's see while I agree that
it's so this is this is going back to
the people were just trying to listen
right now is we did a video talking
about why certain Asian males believe
that all Asian guys have a disadvantage
when it comes to dating women and that
it's damn near impossible for us the
data set of a race which is [ __ ]
stupid as [ __ ] here we go Chris n says
while I agree that it's mainly a
personality and insecurity issue in my
experience with gaming non Asian women
I've come to notice like
passive-aggressive microaggressions okay
for where it sort of makes me double
back a little bit I've dated people
where some had said to be honest I've
never dated an asian guy before I don't
understand what's wrong with saying that
how is it a microaggression I don't know
I mean I've never got into a serious
relationship with a black girl so if I
said that during a date like hey I never
got with a black girl before yeah that
weird cuz that's a fact yeah I don't
understand why that's a microaggression
I don't I don't are you supposed to hide
it maybe he's not explaining it in a way
that maybe I don't know that's a pretty
interesting topic I think it's a good
conversation starter because um if no
one's like I don't know like let's say
well okay well he says sorry because
when I have asked is because they
thought Asian men were a little nerdy
I've never experienced that before like
I've never literally had a date with a
girl who wasn't Asian and yeah I've
never dated an asian guy before and it
was because I thought they were nerdy
I've never
ever ever ever in my experience ever and
mind you I've dated quite a few women
who weren't Asian yeah like so I don't
know I mean I've heard I'm not I want to
discredit him but it probably happened
yeah what I've heard though more common
was that they didn't have an opinion
because they never had an encounter yeah
so like I've heard well cuz I'm from
California right so there's a lot of us
but then I'll hear like yeah there's so
many like cute Asian guys at school but
they don't talk to me and I thought that
they're very cliquish like this coming
from non-asians they think Asians are
cliquish because I think a lot of 80
Bieber clickers yeah they and they think
that asian guys only like asian girls
because that's what they see at school
they just see like Asians just huddling
around in a bubble but I also know in
the Asian circle they don't think that
they're accepted outside so they stay in
their bubble so it's kind of like this
whole who's gonna make the first male
that to be friends or whatever but time
and time again I've heard the same thing
from a lot of women outside of Asian
women don't be like yeah man there's so
many like good-looking Asian guys or
whatever but they never like talk to me
hmm
so I'm like if you don't shoot your shot
bro like you don't get that opportunity
yeah so it says even on dating apps I've
had a few women make inappropriate and
racist jokes about Asian stereotypes I
know but that's but that's not very
particular to just Asian people that
person was gonna make an Asian joke they
were gonna make a black joke Mexican
joke whatever depending on you know
whatever and come on bro like honestly
all that [ __ ] has to go out the window
when you're dating because women test
your strength know your [ __ ] ability
to have a sense of humor your mentality
are you gonna get your panties in a
bunch and at the end of the day I'll
[ __ ] guarantee you man no frickin
girl wants to date a girl now I'm sorry
I'm not doing it very piecey yeah but
but what I mean by that is when they're
in a straight relationship they don't
want to be with a guy that's even more
emotional even more frankly even more
like they
man who's a [ __ ] solid person who's I
don't want to say in control because
it's not about that it's about being
calm and being about [ __ ] like you're
you're not you're not getting your
panties in a bunch every two minutes
it's a [ __ ] nightmare in general to
be with someone that's always being
upset every two [ __ ] minutes I can't
believe you're Davey and it's like what
the [ __ ] dude yeah and so I guess I mean
he seems pretty reasonable because he
goes for me it's really case-by-case cuz
it really depends on the person you're
dating in the perception of Asian men
and it's not Universal across the board
that all women think this way I stand
corrected
haha however I do think that even with
online dating this gets harder to break
past whatever invisible barrier exists
because you're not able to lend us all
that first impression since there's no
interaction and in person like I believe
I can handle myself socially but online
dating is a whole other beast in itself
we're matching is primarily a surface
level superficial means of meeting
people that's why I found out that I've
had more luck meeting new people side
the absent actually interacting with
folks face-to-face yeah 100 percent
agree with that I mean and also alright
put it this way the dating game and the
tinder game is completely different
you have to game it I know there's this
one little Asian kid that he's really
good at the tinder game and he even like
sold a program on how to like do that
well but you got to know each platform
to like how to date I mean there's a
meme that's going around it's like it's
like this is my LinkedIn profile my
facebook profile my Instagram like every
platform you have to figure out the
strategy for each one same with like
your approach at the bar is gonna be
different from your approach within
mutual friends it's you got to adjust to
every situation yeah and so I guess what
he's kind of saying is to is this
he sees the the negative type of
stereotypes that he has to deal with
because before he gets to meet them in
person they have a preconceived notion
of what Asian man is which you know we
agreed like that's that's possible that
that I didn't happen I think what we
were saying is that that's where it
stops for everybody yeah you go cool
this is what people think okay whatever
but you're actually the type of person
that we're saying that we enjoy yeah
because despite that you
still go and you show them what you have
to offer in person yeah so you're
actually it's weird because I know if
you're refuting what we're saying if
you're on our side I think he's he's
just like sizing yeah that hey there are
these barriers that I went through and I
know it's it's circumstantial for the
individual but it is discouraging when I
have to go into that situation yeah for
me when I was mentioning that see I'm
thinking solutions already instead of
being empathetic so if I was in that
situation
it goes two ways you could either own it
you could roast them back or you could
be upset by it and run away it's it's
your choice but for me I took it as I
would take it as a challenge like oh you
want to be races I'll [ __ ] you up too
but I make it playful man I never get
aggressive with women like that like
like don't get your panties in a bunch
and fight them like that's not what a
man like what the [ __ ] dude it's all
good - I think like this guide like
deals with the situation's very well -
he's like well yeah also - if people say
that type of weird I hate using the word
racist idea what I would say just
uneducated yeah uneducated comments then
this is a pretty extreme word so I'm
almost scared away from racism on that
word I'm gonna just say uneducated
right because I had a friend who was
with a ignorant ass like bimbo girl
she's from the valley typical valley
girl right and then he told me they're
all at a party and she was like
basically telling her friends like me
and my boy gonna go fucky-fucky now I'm
like doing that Asian accent she was
white and he's all like all [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna [ __ ] drill that [ __ ] so
she was objectifying him and using that
racist ha ha I'm gonna go fucky-fucky
him trying to get [ __ ] so this is like
who's really ok so who's really the one
on top here like yeah he he went right
back and degraded or heard like womanís
like I [ __ ] I'm gonna pound that [ __ ]
whatever he said his thing and everyone
laughed she said a racist thing whatever
right but they were cool with that yeah
and that's all circumstantial stuff - so
I'm pretty sure like that's more like
you know they had that relationship so
it kind of makes sense you get away with
a lot more [ __ ] when you're when you
know
the person yeah if it makes sense I mean
yeah I agree with this guy that 100%
like that I think he acknowledges that
there are things that from his
experience an Asian man goes through but
he's also the type of guy that we like
because it's like it doesn't [ __ ]
matter though I'm still gonna go on this
date yeah and I think I think just using
the word racism in that kind of sense
it's kind of a pretty extreme because
she still wanted to go on a date with
you I'm only talking about guys who are
quick to change their the mood of the
situation and get all upset yeah so like
you know what I'm talking about right
they get like what do you mean by that
and it is like oh my god yeah you're
you're such a little yeah don't even not
explain it like and man I know I'm gonna
get all [ __ ] up for butchering the
example when I said like girls don't
want to date girls at the end of the day
right like there is regardless of your
gay lesbian straight there is feminine
energy and there's masculine energy is
what I'm trying to point out and not
necessarily the gender girl girl guy guy
right yeah and he each relationship I
think that a feminine doesn't want
another feminine energy cut again in the
yank on exactly that might point out is
like okay so and if you're in a straight
relationship I'm a woman's looking for a
man and I know these days it's
controversial because gender is such a
topic that's taboo right now right but I
think that when you're in these
situations right you're sexualizing each
other you're seeing if if if this is a
good mate not only that is this someone
that I can rely on and you got to think
about the characteristics of females
looking for if she's feminine and she
doesn't necessarily have to be feminine
in the traditional sense like like make
a sandwich [ __ ] like that degrading
feminine yeah I'm talking about like if
she wants someone that's going to be her
rock or support someone who's a lead or
someone who's this or someone who was a
partner when I say leader day time
I'm not making her a subordinate or
whatever but like someone who's
confident someone who they can rely on I
guarantee you she's testing you on the
[ __ ] debt date just like you should
be testing her but when when when
they're doing this kind of stuff they're
seeing if you get upset quick they're
seeing like what kind of a human being
you are also just don't read into too
much it when I first date man it's the
first day just chill that's what I
always fun right that's fine dissection
too much sometimes man when I'm on a
first date I'm just trying to chop it up
and see if I like you first that way you
get into deeper conversation on the
second date if the first date happens to
just steer that way then yeah but you
know don't I guess like if you're
looking to develop a relationship don't
[ __ ] on the [ __ ] first date men like
good relationships could come from that
too about the energy level man but yeah
it's not explained I think I got a we
could do a whole other podcast about
that feminine and female and a male
energy the yin and yang
we don't put enough emphasis on that
like everything is such blanket [ __ ]
everything is so like there's just a
general rule to everything yeah and I'm
like why do people think like this it's
crazy really this one this one
interesting okay
being a Hmong woman I used to say I
didn't like Asian men and I would never
date slash marry one
growing up in the Hmong tradition with
the idea drilled into our heads on how
men have roles and women are forced to
fit in this mold from such a young age
was very upsetting it's very true I know
a lot of Hmong people in Sacramento they
told me about [ __ ] like this like this
is like an old tradition where they
would go into the house and get at them
and [ __ ] like it's it's my shirt fits
pretty sure it's really not practiced
that widely now but that was like some
old traditional [ __ ] I would just steal
the women in the middle of the night or
some [ __ ] now that I've grown up and
I've brought in my sense of thinking and
understanding of Who I am as a person I
realize it wasn't that I didn't like
Asian men it was I didn't like certain
traits about Asian men I was surrounded
by in my family and I thought all Asian
men carry these traits because of all
the men and my family were the same if I
felt they were shallow spoiled and
grateful and ignorant so throughout my
life I steered away from Asian men but I
got older and saw that not all all Asian
men are Hmong and not all Asian races
carry these traditions on straight
rules that I fortunately broke out of
and thinking back I truly wish I had
been more open-minded when I was younger
maybe then I would have seen Asian men
in a different light and now I'm dating
a Mexican funny that's another topic
that I think people wanted us to talk
about they're like hey man like you guys
are bashing Asian guys but what about
all the asian girls that hate themselves
and date white guys and I'm like [ __ ]
themselves and I'm like take them who
cares
take them that's their problem or like
their prerogative right that's not a
problem but if you want me to comment on
that I've made a video about this before
and I said why is it that when we make
this approach to it's almost as if
you're entitled to these Asian girls and
they don't have a choice
yeah but also if they have self-hate
they have self-hate [ __ ] them no but
there's a other part of me that's like
now okay just like this girl situation
she's like it was my own family I was
fighting against and usually that's the
case when she says when a asian girl
says I only date white guys she had a
very bad experience with Asian men it
could be dark it could be she was
molested by her family members it could
be she was abused physically she
probably has a deadbeat [ __ ] father
or sometimes these Asian girls only grew
up around white dudes there's a lot of
debt so variables that's the flavor
they're used to is what it is man or
they could I've met batshit crazy Asian
women where they're just a little too
nuts for our culture but you know
they've peas in a pod right like they
find other crazy guys of other cultures
that will date them there's so many
different variables but in at the end of
the day if people want to hate
themselves let them [ __ ] hate
themselves don't obsess over it yeah why
you why you obsessed over this one
[ __ ] [ __ ] individual like it
she's this self-hating Asian girl that's
just heard like you just can't let her
represent all the other Asian woman and
then scorn you from that [ __ ] yeah
because like for me too I never thought
I'd be with the Korean girl because of
just the type of woman that I ground
with were mainly Vietnamese and black
and Mexican so like I didn't grow up
around too many Korean women I'm a mom
and my mom is [ __ ] a psychopath yeah
like I'm like I'm good off that but
turns out I'm engaged to a Korean girl
like she she wasn't a top in your prior
they were friends it was not right it
was like Vietnamese girls right yeah
like my my [ __ ] was straight up
Vietnamese and [ __ ] Mexican is what
it was and also black girls too but it's
but it just that's just because that's
what I grew up with and people think I
have a white fetish but at the end of
the day I have a nice ass fetish yeah
booty fetish and to me I okay at the end
of the day the way I look at it is this
um not a lot of women will put up with
me I'm [ __ ] crazy
yeah so to me I'm like thankful that
anybody would stay with me I've said
this on another pack podcast to them all
like guys like it's hard enough to keep
a relationship period it's not [ __ ]
easy man so when you're out here hating
on other people for dating interracially
or maybe they have a preference or
whatever like guys dude [ __ ] who
cares it's hard yeah love it's like who
cares man also you're in America too is
just a melting pot of a bunch of random
[ __ ] people is bound to happen it
really is like just just to be upset at
somebody else for dating outside their
race because you feel like they're
backstabbing your culture you do realize
you're in America right like this is
America this this isn't we're like it's
a mixing pot of multiple culture so it's
bound to happen and it's gonna happen
more and more often especially after my
generation - yeah gets more and more
like that especially in this country
it's just how this country is
progressing if you wanted to stay in one
area you wanted to date only your
culture you should probably stayed in
your country then yeah it sounded a
little Trumpy when I said that but [ __ ]
but I'm saying like stay in your country
it's like if you're used to having
things the way that you wanted that you
liked in that country then why'd you
move in the first place Yeah right
that's something my dad had to learn he
didn't understand why I was so cold and
quote American it's like bro you raised
me here understand that no I think my
mom had to break it down to him my mom
literally told him like yo you're the
reason why we came to this country yeah
so how can you be mad at your son for
having a mare
and dreams in American wads if you
wanted him to be a Korean Korean kid
because day Korea yeah should have
stayed in close reading and why you saw
chairman dad were in Germany yeah nice
nice Minh do it a lot of [ __ ] a lot
of Mario's friends - they're all married
- like white people Oh interesting I
don't like I for me I don't understand
it you know only because I know that
they grew up mainly around Asian people
well their neighborhood was half-asian
half-white though right no probably
right so like for me I can't I it was
hard for me to see me date somebody who
was or be in a long-term relationship
with somebody who was white because I
see something I didn't grow up with and
culturally we didn't really mesh that
well but I found a lot of cultural
similarities with [ __ ] Mexican people
in black people so yes same here it was
a lot easier yeah that's really just
what it boils down to there's really no
deep thought into it other than that
it's just uncomfortable with but what
I've noticed though is yes there's that
culture but at the end of the day class
culture to me I connect way more than
ethnic culture mmm because yeah I
connected a lot with with Jess even
though you know she's of the tortilla
skin yes the tortillas kid because if
you think about it right like even
within Asians I connect more with other
races that came from the same economic
background that I did in the upbringing
like now then I do with rich Asians rich
Asian kids
I have friends but it's hard to like
deeply connect because it's just
different man their thought their the
way that they go by making friends
everything and I don't want to make a
blanket statement but my personal
experience throughout life has been that
yeah might be different now man yeah
it's it's all about what we bring to the
table man I mean just to wrap this up I
mean if I could give you another example
there was a girl that I dated we did it
for a couple of months but she
specifically only dated black dudes and
I was her first Asian boyfriend but what
she ate it she was Filipino oh so she
was basically black and they're like all
like if you all know I feel like
Filipino people in Samoan people they're
like the closest thing to being like
black
as possible there's a hip-hop Asians I
think Filipinos are like the Porto Rican
for occasions because they had that
Latin flavor and there's like black kind
of flavor and Chinese people are the
Mexicans of Asians like clothes thing
you get a Mexican but uh yeah I was the
first and I remember I was the first
Asian guy that she everybody I had no
idea I didn't know that she like
specifically only Nathan black dudes
until she met me and she we were the
Gateway I was I was a gateway drug I
don't know who she's with now but you
know that was kind of cool I was like oh
[ __ ] and you know I remember I asked her
I was like well why'd you decide to date
me she let know that you liked you
that's it yeah that's that's all that it
was she had a preconceived perception of
what she wanted in a male and it was a
long dick black guy and that she got
herself an average dick Korean fat
Korean dude and she enjoyed it as she
actually said after I broke up with her
that I was the best boyfriend that she
ever had Wow yeah because of the way
they treated her it's all about
individual leaving a mark on a person's
impression just by yourself and just
being responsible for that man yeah and
it was a very weird statement for her to
say that after I broke up with her
because we were barely together for that
long
shitty was you treated before I met that
kind of freaked me out a little bit the
younger we are too we basically have the
most shadiest experiences yeah sure well
guys that wraps up this podcast is
basically a follow up of that last
podcast hope that clarified a few things
leave in the comments below have
conversation like you guys can agree or
disagree it's completely fine just don't
don't yell at people man and we go in
there and talk some [ __ ] too
yeah sometimes I just talk to you just
talk [ __ ] but remember every Thursday
and every Sunday there's a genius brain
podcast different topics we're just here
to be with you on your commute if you
see us on that iTunes give us that five
star if you're in YouTube give us a
thumbs up share this [ __ ] with everybody
else and leave in the comments below
about stuff that you want to see or
discuss about the topic that we're
talking about today we will see you all
next time [ __ ] happy birthday to you